[Applause]
and I want to congratulate my former
secretary liberal Marty Walsh you guys
know Marty I tell you what if you have
to be in a foxhole you want Marty next
to you you want Marty with you
he's a man of his work
the problem is he knows more than you do
and more than I do
not Lifetime Achievement Award but you
got a lot I gotten a whole other
lifetime to work out here but Marty and
you you may be uh you may be carrying a
hockey stick these days but uh
but I'm still coming for you man
thank you all for your continued support
of Julie Sue she worked hand in hand
with Marty and she's going to be a great
secretary labor
it's all good to see you guys this feels
like coming home you know
well
you know uh I'm here because there's no
better place to talk about the progress
we made together and wouldn't been made
without you and that's not hyperbole
that's a fact our economic plan is
working we now have to finish the job
but there's more to do and you're
leading the way shovels in the ground
cranes in the air factories opening that
all those jobs meaning we created